a big story from the world of sports
after months of speculation quarterback
Tom Brady announced on social media that
he will not return to the New England
Patriots next season surprised a lot of
people with that multiple reports say
Brady will instead become a Tampa Bay
Buccaneer CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson is in New York
City's Times Square Dana good morning a
lot of people say Brady is the best
quarterback of all time what do we know
about him becoming a Buccaneer well Tony
a lot of people do say that and they
would be right here from the crossroads
of the world I can tell you that Brady's
that have crossroads in his career
there's no imminent announcement planned
right now but we do know that Tampa Bay
according to multiple sources is where
Brady will try to recreate the magic he
made in New England will never see this
one again Jim Rhaenys pass it's
intercepted in the turn unexpected at
the time this was Tom Brady's final play
in New England an interception return
for a touchdown
following two decades of glory in the
NFL you know there's nobody who's had a
better career I would say to me that
career reads like a fairy tale Brady
came into the league in 2000 as a
relatively unknown quarterback just
happy to compete for a spot on the
Patriots pretty good work ethic so I
think I get the job done but that work
ethic put Brady on a path to
superstardom he set more than 50 NFL
records with the Patriots including six
championships and 249 wins the most by
any player in January 2012 Patriots
owner Robert Kraft reminisced about his
first meeting with Brady this is a hug
mr. Kraft I'm Tom Brady I know who you
are you're our six round draft choice
from Michigan and he looked me in the
eye and he said and I'm the best
decision this organization has ever made
now 42 years old the superstar
quarterback will spend the twilight of
his career in a new city something Brady
hinted at after his playoff loss I love
playing for this team again
just I don't know what it looks like
moving forward so will this take it day
by day in Brady's open letter to fans
Tuesday he wrote quote I will always
love you and what we have shared a
lifetime full of fun memories I'm
surprised to be honest with you I
thought he was going back in a CBS
Sports NFL analyst Pete Prisco says
while Brady has nothing to prove his
drive to be the best outside New England
will push him he's a competitor you see
him on the field he's fire he's feisty
he wants to show everybody that he can
win one without Bill Belichick Brady's
expected deal with Tampa Bay reportedly
in the 30 million dollar range the Tampa
Bay does not play the Patriots this year
but I should point out the Super Bowl is
in Tampa and Gail no host city has ever
had its home team play in that title
game who knows maybe more mystery for
Tom Brady a lot of people still in shock
Dana do you think this was just a
financial decision many people still
can't believe this is actually happening
yeah it may have been we talked about
this at the time when Brady's season had
ended that the idea was that Brady may
have some money in mind but that the
Patriots need to start looking forward
and they may not have
it could have been it could have simply
been the opportunity to move on
somewhere else with New England wanting
to start over it's still hard
thank you very much Dana I just left Tom
Brady and Robert Kraft together and they
built it's I'm still a little stunned I
almost don't imagine it